et donc moi je vais vous parler d'amour
lorsque je suis n'est donc à ma
naissance en ami proche de mon père mme
écrit une lettre dans laquelle on peut
le dire il te faudra retenir qu'il n'ait
rien de si commun que de parler d'amour
mais rien de si rare que dans bien
parlons c'est donc ce que je vais
essayer de faire avec vous aujourd'hui
l'invisible est quand même extrêmement
vaste c'est un sujet très reste il se
trouve que lorsque je faisais mon
premier passage mon livre de chevet
étaient risibles amours de pointe des
rares avec une association dans laquelle
j'étais on a emprunté une soirée est le
nom de cette soirée était love sex gmbh
et ça marche toujours nu en anglais
c'est à partir de là que je commence à
faire le lien entre le amour est
invisible parce qu'au final
l'amour c'est quelque chose d'un
perceptible c'est quelque chose d'un
touchable j'espère que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi c'est un visible
l'invisible est un sujet complexe
je pense que l'amour elle est peut-être
encore plus parce que nous y sommes tous
conviés sans exception l'amour est
propre à chacun mais il se vit souvent à
plusieurs
l'amour est universel commun à tous mais
il est intrinsèquement différentes et
c'est tous ces paradoxes qui font la
beauté de ce sentiment
lors de mon année de cm1 après que mes
parents se soient séparés et que mon
amoureuse de l'époque me délaisse pour
un garçon un peu plus grand qu'il
faisait du tennis je remets en cause
tous les films disney que j'ai pu voir
qu'ils dépeignent un amour un peu cinglé
surtout éternelle j'ai même pourrait le
vendre les commentaires envoyés fin
signé avec mes parents une charte comme
quoi je ne me marierai jamais
donc c'est pour vous dire donc l'amour
fait peur mais a enfin je me ferait peur
l'amour mais il se trouve que l'amour
est quand même très persévérant lamouri
coriace et donc deux années plus tard en
sixième je pense que je tombe amoureux à
mon échelle
je tombe amoureux et seulement huit ans
plus tard seulement huit ans plus tard
ben je sors avec cette même personne
parce que bon voilà boutant sur le front
et un manque de confiance oblige ce
n'est que de 8 ans plus tard que je sors
avec cette même personne et après trois
ans d'amour finalement bas je pense que
certains ici connaissent le théorème de
novembre à le stepper on l'a fait tomber
beaucoup malheureusement bête comme je
suis je suis tombé dedans cet amour a
pris forme
cet amour a pris fin et maintenant j'en
suis là avec vous à me demander ma
pourquoi est ce qu'on aime
pourquoi aime-t-on pourquoi est-ce qu'on
est fous un jour de cette personne et
l'autre jour non c'est plein de question
que je me pose que vous posez aussi donc
je vous parle comme si au final vous
étiez mes thérapeutes
parce que bon j'aborde le thème de
l'amour ou mais au final
qui suis-je pour en parler du haut de
mes 23 ans et demi quelques expériences
j'abhorre c'était dicks principalement
pour quelque chose je viens en croisade
pour vous convaincre d'une chose que
nous aborderons ensemble même si je ne
suis pas expert avant que mes potes qui
ne regarde cette vidéo de moi disons que
je suis amateur je décrirais l'amour
comme une espèce de sentiment de
plénitude d'un sentiment de satisfaction
c'est un peu comme un petit virus qui
nous fait faire tout et n'importe quoi
avant même qu'on s'en rende compte
néanmoins le monde qui nous entoure est
de plus en plus basée sur l'avenue on a
bien évidemment les séries les films que
l'on binge sans cesse on a aussi les
applications goût de notre nom qu'on
regarde tous les jours même nos cours
sont de plus en plus avoir enfin il ya
de plus en plus de 2 des changes entre
le notre vision et nos cours c'est donc
à ce moment-là que je commence à me
demander comment faire pour continuer à
dessiner quelque chose
d'invisibles alors que on est tellement
habitué à voir c'est pour ça que vous
propose qu'on aille de l'invisible vers
le visible comprendre tout d'abord bas
on va faire comme tout le monde on va
essayer de reprendre un peu l'histoire
de l'amour parce qu'au final ce
sentiment vous le savez tous il existe
deux là depuis la nuit des temps
il a été libéré cachez interdit à
l'antiquité par exemple les jeunes
aristocrates remparts dont les
aristocrates en général ont des élèves
et ils ont le droit tout simplement de
d'échangés enfin d'avoir des relations
avec ses élèves
le mariage existe à cette période là
mais la femme elle est interdite de tout
infidélité ce qui bien évidemment n'est
pas le cas des aristocrates ensuite
hommage au moyen âge on est en amour qui
est lui beaucoup plus courtois on est en
amour qui est beaucoup plus courtois qui
est beaucoup plus chevaleresque dans les
poésies et les écrits tout simplement on
voit de plus en plus d'amour pur et
profond d'amour authentique ensuite on
peut voir à la renaissance
un amour qui est lui décrit comme
platonique platon qui lui vient de
l'antiquité et cet amour il est purement
intellectuel il est purement
intellectuel et il se vit hors de toute
sensualité tout simplement au xviiie
siècle
c'est maintenant au tour du romantisme
et lui le romantisme c'est un amour qui
est plus tourné vers soi donc le plus
important c'est le fait de se sentir
aimé je me sens aimé et donc je me sens
vivant je me sens souffrir et donc je me
sens vivant c'est le fait de se pincer
le moyen pour eux de se sentir exister
pardon donc forcément ces personnes se
tournent vers un amour vers une personne
qui est qu'ils ne les aiment pas pas du
tout pas assez pour justement avoir de
la jouissance dans la souffrance
il est aussi intéressant maintenant de
se demander quand est il aujourd'hui
qu'en est il de l'amour aujourd'hui je
suis persuadé qu' il faut pas réduire
l'amour moderne quand je parle de
l'amour d'aujourd'hui c'est plus nos
générations
génération qu'on pourrait qualifier
cinder il faut pas généraliser en disant
voilà notre amour et est destiné à être
seulement des multitudes de photos
prises sous notre meilleur homme une
belle description bien catchy et une
multitude de swype à droite et si vous
ne me croyez pas vous pouvez aller voir
amour solitaire c'est une page en ce
temps on page rasta g qui en gros
récupère des messages que vous et moi
aurait pu envoyer qui les récupèrent et
qu'il est anonyme et qu'il les met sur
la page et c'est vraiment plein de beaux
mots qui ont du sens et qui sont
magnifiques ils en ont même fait un
livre 1 re et qu'eric de tous ces
magnifiques j'allais dire poèmes mais ce
n'est que des textos au final et
savourer considéra je pense avec les
plus beaux au travers de l'amour au fil
des siècles
l'amour est donc une l'amour et muse de
photographes de peintres de chanteurs
d'artistes mêmes d'architectes l'amour
fait couler beaucoup d'encre l'amour
fait couler beaucoup d'encre mais il
fait aussi couler des larmes je pense qu
on a tous vécu ici parce que au final
l'amour c'est un sentiment d'immense
grand et comme toute chose que l'on ne
comprend pas vraiment eu nous fait peur
l'amour est donc lié à de nombreux maux
à l'amour est lié par exemple à
l'érotomanie qui désigne quelqu'un qui
est persuadé que quelqu'un d'autre
l'aiment à la folie ou encore le
narcissisme qui désigne quelqu'un qui
porte beaucoup trop d'attention ou
beaucoup trop d'amour par gonds en verre
en vers sa propre personne
maintenant que nous avons une vision
plus globale de l'amour revenons à notre
problématique qui était donc comment
déceler l'invisible quand nous sommes
tant habitués à voir pour moi il est
vraiment primordial puis l'on sache
trouver ce petit trésor
malheureusement on n'a ni carte ni
boussole pour le trouver véritablement
et c'est pour ça qu'on en vient à
trouver nos propres repères personnels
on en vient troubler nos propres
personnes personnels et parmi tous ses
repères j'aimerais que vous sachiez que
dans un premier temps l'amour est
nécessaire
c'est vraiment une affirmation que je
vous fais j'en suis convaincu et donc
pour vous pour vous prouver pour vous le
prouver par de même si je pense que vous
êtes d'accord avec moi je vous parlais
de l'empereur frédéric ii c'est
rentrèrent dont je tairai l'origine
parce que vous allez encore avoir une
dent contre les allemands a fait venir
six nourrissons six orphelins qui donc
sont gardés par par des nourrices et
c'est nourrissent 11 pour seule mission
de s'assurer de leurs besoins
biologiques
donc ils sont nourris on s'assure qu'ils
dorment correctement on s'assure aussi
qu'ils mangent bien évidemment enfin me
nourris qu'ils ne mangent avec ils
dorment pardon est donc la seule
interdiction concerne oury sang versé
bbc de leur parler et d'interagir
socialement avec eux doutent pas de
calan pas d'amour donné et le résultat
de cette expérience est totalement
tragique
tout simplement parce que les six bébés
meurent les civils humeur et cela
explique que l'humain a profondément
besoin d'amour le mall humain voilà
c'est nécessaire pour le nom maroc on
sait que c'est nécessaire on ne sait
toujours pas comment le déceler
correctement mais au final 1
même s'il est difficile à déceler c'est
peut-être un autre de le comprendre et
de lâcher prise
parce que pour en avoir discuté autour
de moi il ya quelque chose qui revient
vraiment très fréquemment
c'est le fait que deux personnes
lorsqu'ils ont un échange réciproque
il ya comme si il y avait quelque chose
qui jouait sur lequel on n'avait
absolument pas prise
comme en espèce de lien invisible
justement et c'est comme si deux
inconscients disputer entre eux ils
cette chose au final j'ai l'impression
qu'il faut juste l'accepter et le
laisser aller ensuite qu'il faut savoir
aussi c'est que j'ai parlé pour
l'instant je pense que vous avez la même
perception
j'ai énormément parlé de l'amour de
couple mais l'amour existe sous de
nombreuses formes l'amour par exemple
c'est l'amour familial
personnellement je pense que sans ça je
ne serai absolument rien mais il existe
aussi l'amour pour un hobby pour un
sport pour un lieu qu'on chérit un lieu
qu'on adore
ou même pour de la musique je pense
qu'on est nombreux ici un tout
simplement aimer la musique donc toutes
ses formes d'amour nous rassure on a
beaucoup parlé d'histoire mais au final
contrairement à son prédécesseur qui en
a énormément parlé extrêmement bien on a
peu parlé d'amour à deux pendant 2 de
sciences excusez moi ont fait que ça
parlait d'amour
on a peu parlé de sciences donc on a
parlé d'histoire mais pas de science et
on vit au 21e siècle il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on peut de manière très
hostile mieux comprendre bas comment
agit l'amour tout simplement par exemple
avec les niveaux de dopamine qui au qui
augmente d'aussitôt style pour les
femmes et de testostérone trois hommes
voilà
on préféra le prix total ventromédian
qui lui alors et comme s'il était ivre
ne comprend absolument rien à ce qui se
passe et c'est donc à partir de là que
l'expression l'amour rend aveugle existe
c'est encore un bolivien d'ailleurs en
visibilité et le mans et il ya aussi par
exemple l'endorphine ou alors la
dopamine qui eux augmenté explique par
exemple le fait que ce soit totalement
dans un ressenti qui soit exagérée ou
alors une dans une forêt au début d'une
relation
donc au final la science nous permet de
mieux comprendre ce qui l'amour
ce qu'il faut aussi savoir pour qu'on
soit plus à l'aise avec l'amour c'est le
fait que l'amour est liée est intimement
liée à nos sens
en effet la vue l'ouïe l'odorat ou
encore l'équilibré réception il est
intimement liée à nos sens et nous
permettent de mieux interpréter bas tout
simplement l'amour
on a les mains moites le papillon les
papillons dans le ventre pardon ou
encore le coeur qui s'emballe et donc
toutes ces choses se sont vraiment comme
des petits détecteurs qui nous disent
bon voilà ce qui se passe non non donc
voilà sont maintenant que après vous
avoir dit tout ça que je vous fasse une
confidence
parce que c'est un peu comme si je vous
avais utilisés comme des thérapeutes
parce que finale de l'amour je n'en sais
rien et ça me fait aussi extrêmement
peur je ne sais pas si vous êtes venu en
essayant de le savoir plus mais voilà
fallait que je vous en parle fallait que
je vous parle de cette anxiété fallait
que vous parle de cette trouille mais
heureusement il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça j'ai aussi pu lire des citations
d'alfred musset qui m'a énormément
rassuré et qui m'a fait du bien et
j'espère qu'ils aient vous aussi vous en
ferez
tous les hommes sont menteurs inconstant
faux bavard hypocrite
orgueilleux méprisable et sensuelle
toutes les femmes sont perfides
artificieuse vaniteuse curieuse et
dépravé le monde n'étant n'est qu'un
égout sans fond où les phoques les plus
d'informer rang et se tordent sur des
montagnes de forage
il ya au monde une chose sainte est
sublime c'est l'union de ces deux êtres
si imparfait et si affreux on est
souvent trompés en amour souvent blessé
malheureux mais on aime et quand on est
sur le bord de sa tombe
on se retourne pour regarder en arrière
et on se dit j'ai souffert souvent je me
suis trompé quelquefois mais j'ai aimé
c'est moi qui ai vécu et non pas un être
factice créé par mon orgueil et par
moments
donc voilà maintenant soyons donc
rassurés il faut que l'on se rassure
parce que peut penser que l'amour est
nécessaire on sait que l'amour existe
sous de nombreuses formes
on sait que l'amour est accessible à
tous on sait que l'amour est liée à nos
sens et que ses sens ne sont plus
faciles à interpréter
alors on peut donc dès lors lancé une
vaste opération des distributions
d'amour parce que ingénieurs de demain
retenez bien l'amour est la seule chose
avec un rendement supérieur à 1 qui nous
permet de recevoir plus que nous mêmes
avons déjà donné
en effet c'est la seule chose qui
augmente lorsque nous mêmes la
partageons
soyons donc conscient ne nous retenons
plus à acceptons le partageons
je vous souhaite à tous d
[Applaudissements]